it's great to be joined today by Ron fry
a green beret warrior king of the pêche
Valley entrepreneur and author of the
book hammerhead six how Green Berets
waged an unconventional war against the
Taliban to win in Afghanistan's deadly
pêche Valley the book is fascinating Ron
and it's such a pleasure to be speaking
with you today you know I think when
most people learn about the tactics and
strategies employed by the American
military in the Middle East they they
hear more about strategies that are not
what you were involved in when you were
in the pêche Valley so talk to us a
little bit about your deployment there
and and what you did great well hey
thanks first of all thanks for having me
on pleasure you know right after the
Taliban fell in 2001-2002 timeframe you
know there's this big power vacuum and
we're trying to help this this country
get on its feet they're still like you
know pockets of al Qaeda and Taliban
that are in the area when my team got
deployed there we were in the the Kunar
province which you know the history of
the war would show was the hottest part
of the of the fight or the most
difficult place to fight and we were
just trying to figure it out there was
only a few boots on the ground and we
just got this unique mission that
there's this valley where they knew al
Qaeda was operating they knew that
there's Taliban operatives there was all
kinds of cartels and other people in
this valley and we got the we got the
job to go into the valley and attempt to
win the people over and deny the enemy's
sanctuary in that valley and that's the
essence of what our mission was and so
we had to you know like you alluded to
we couldn't take the heavy-handed
approach of going in there with a
thousand men and trying to force these
people to either work with us or submit
to us we actually had to go out there
and win them over and you know people
talk about hearts and minds but we
actually had to go there and make
friends and recruit soldiers from the
local people to actually work with us
can you talk a little bit about some of
the sort of day to day maybe even some
of the mundane stuff that you had to
sort of learn and integrate and and live
within in or
to start to be accepted into the
community yes you know the the huge
advantage we had is when we showed up
all the American soldiers they'd seen
before were clean-shaven young uniformed
soldiers and all of a sudden you have
these older Americans that have beards
that are kind of wearing some local
clothes that are willing to talk to the
shopkeeper that are buying you know our
Pepsi's and stuff on the local economy
so immediately when we got there there
is about a two-week honeymoon period
where they thought these new Americans
were Muslim they kind of accepted us
immediately and were like okay these
guys are different and then you know
that kind of wore off and and then it
was like we actually had to do our job
but you know on a day-to-day basis I was
trying to run a camp so I've got some
Marines that are working with us my team
some Afghans they weren't mercenaries
but they were working for us and you
know we had to deal with the day-to-day
where you had people bringing their kids
up that needed medical care we had
people working on the camp doing labor
we had Afghan soldiers that we were
working with that we were training and
then probably five or six times a day I
would get called down to the local
district leaders house and either you
know adjudicate some dispute between
villages or make a decision with a
contractor it was like we were running
almost like the mayor's office of this
of this valley and we're supposed to be
you know the the strength and the I was
considered like the local warlord but at
the same time I was I was their guest
and I was kind of helping them with
their local politics where some of the
disputes they had they couldn't they
couldn't fix themselves they needed a
third party to come in and basically be
the referee what was the language
situation how was the communication
happening on a day to day basis so all
Special Forces teams have language
skills unfortunate thing my team was an
Asian team so we had like eight
different Asian languages but nobody
spoke posh tune and so we had a couple
of key interpreters that had been vetted
by the CIA before and they just would
help us with with all the translating
can you sort of relate or maybe give us
an analogy to so for people who don't
know your background you went to Brigham
Young you spent two years
a missionary for the Mormon Church in
France and Switzerland yes can you talk
a little bit about how well number one
how that experience related directly to
your work in the pest valley but also
maybe ways in which it was drastically
different what you were doing there and
what you were doing as a Mormon
missionary yes that's a great question
you know as a Mormon missionary in
Switzerland
you know most missionaries in other
parts of the world they do a lot of
humanitarian aid both my brothers serve
their Muslims in Chile and about half
the time they were doing more Peace
Corps type stuff as opposed to direct
service for the church in Switzerland in
France I got to meet a ton of Muslims
people from every different faith and we
got to do service we also got to
proselyting but I got a real
understanding of the world is a big
place there's a lot of different
ideologies a lot of different people a
lot of different thoughts and spend a
lot of time listening to people hearing
their life stories hearing what was
driving them and I felt when we were in
Afghanistan that skill set was directly
transferable in the fact that these
people want to be heard they want to
know that whatever decision you're
making or for whatever reason you're
there that you understand where they're
coming from whether that's what they
want their government to do what they
don't want the US military to do you
know the goals they have for their kids
etc the ability to listen and actually
take their point of view into account
was directly transferable what wasn't
was you do that during the day and then
at night when you get Intel that the
enemy is doing something another place
and then you strap on the guns and go
they're looking for a fight that was
that was not directly transferable the
people skills the that was transferable
but that was really the difference you
know sometimes I felt like I was more
like a missionary during the day and
then when you know bullets would start
flying then you switch right back into
Green Beret or army mode when you see
the discussions that happen currently in
media among elected officials that
relate to whether it's Isis or really
and any other group or area where there
could be a potential military incursion
by the United States or a joint group of
the United States and allies is there
anything that based on your experience
in the past Valley you find to be just
sort of fundamentally missing from
either the understanding of what will
need to be done in order to root out the
ideology of a group like Isis or the
tactics and strategies are you seeing
that there's anything in particular
missing from discussions you know the
the thing that I see that is in place is
in Syria we do have right now the focus
is having Special Forces work with the
Kurds and rebel groups etc that that
part is is somewhat encouraging what you
see missing is the fundamental
understanding of what these people want
not our enemy but the people were trying
to turn to coordinate with you know the
conflict in that part of the world
between Shia and Sunni between the
different nation-states that's that's
been going on forever and we I don't
know that we take into account the fact
that when we when we come in there to
solve a problem that we see as our
problem are we galvanizing those people
to now join hands and fight against the
foreigners or are we actually leveraging
you know the moderate friendly side if
we can identify what that is against the
site you know that that is a common
enemy because you've got you do have the
moderates you do have the reasonable
people over there that are fighting
against the violent jihadists that are
also trying to take over those
nation-states
and some wise you know when we talk
about killing Isis well destroying this
gang of guys doesn't solve the long-term
problem will create another vacuum or
just another group will pop up and so I
you know I'm hopeful that there'll be
more discussion about a more holistic
approach of ballistics not the word I'm
looking for but a comprehensive strategy
for the Middle East not just hey the
next 18 months against Isis and I don't
know that the last few ministrations
that there's been a real comprehensive
Middle East strategy you mentioned
something that's been a discussion we've
been having for many years on this
program which is if we can identify who
the so-called the good guys are or who
our best ally is the US has a very long
history of arming and ultimately
fighting against groups that we armed
who still have the weapons we armed them
with so as some
one who has actually been there doing
this type of work talk to us about some
of the pragmatic difficulties day-to-day
in identifying so so-called good guys
not at the 30,000 foot level of
countries or large groups but even
within something like the pêche Valley
where you worked yeah no and you know
it's it's very especially with the
American society you were a microwave
society we expect everything really
quick creating relationships that are
going to work with us long term
sometimes we're really impatient if it
seems like this guy's enemy is our enemy
then we'll work with him and destroy
that enemy next thing you know we just
empowered someone that's even worse and
in the pêche Valley was no different
it was difficult when somebody would
come with intel on the al Qaeda guy or
hey we think this village over in turns
Taliban to really vet through are they
actually wanting me to help them destroy
their enemy or are they giving the Intel
about a common enemy hmm and more often
than not there'd be a blood feud or a
village that was fighting against
another village that just came to us and
tell to tell us that their enemy was the
Taliban or al-qaeda and it's very
tempting to strap on the guns and go
fight what we perceive as being our
enemy and to get pulled into a trap
where we're just participating in a
blood feud so we would really just take
patience and we would like try and
gather more Intel around the people that
were proposing to share with us
sometimes we'd find out that they were
they were genuine these are people that
have been friends of the Afghan
government in the past they were
reasonable they were moderate they were
giving us fair Intel and other times we
just found out that these were guys were
just trying to you know get the drop on
their enemy and use us as the as the
strong man so you know but I think in
all of these conflicts and this is the
nature of unconventional warfare you
need guys on the ground that are willing
to take the time in the effort to try
and get to know who these people
actually are not just so we can
accomplish what we're trying to do in
the next year or two but so that we know
all the players on the ground for a long
term strategy so that 30 years from now
we have a cadre of friends and allies
that we've got a long history with so
that what happened on you know 9/11
doesn't I mean 9/11 we'd walked away
from Afghanistan for
years and we didn't have a good idea of
who was where what was what who was our
friend and and that and that created
part of the problem we've been speaking
in part about the experiences that Ron
Fry discusses in his book hammerhead six
how Green Berets waged an unconventional
war against the Taliban to win in
Afghanistan's deadly pêche Valley we
have been speaking with the book's
author Ron fry Green Beret thank you so
much for talking to us about this super
interesting thank you